jeff bezos has become the first human
being on the planet to be worth
200 billion dollars yes you heard that
right
200 billion it was marked at 1 50 pm
eastern time on august 26th
after amazon's stock went up 2 this not
only maintains his spot as the world's
richest person
but it also makes him worth 90 billion
dollars more than his runner-up
bill gates who is currently worth 116.1
billion dollars
even adjusting for inflation we at
forbes believe
bezos's fortune is the largest ever
tract in history
not surprisingly consumer habits from
the coronavirus pandemic are the big
reason amazon's worth has shot up this
year
the company's stock is up nearly 80
percent since the beginning of 2020.
bezos owns roughly 11 of amazon which
makes up more than 90 percent of his
fortune
he also owns the washington post
aerospace company blue origin
and some other private investments bezos
would have actually been
even richer if it wasn't for his divorce
with mackenzie scott last july
as part of the split he agreed to give
her 25
of his amazon stake which is now worth
63 billion dollars
you